جاء برنامج نتفليكس تاجر في مقدمه الوظائف
الجانبيه التي ازدهرت في عام 2022 والتي
يتوقع ان تنمو بنسبه
5400 في المئه هذا العام بكل بساطه تشاهد
محتوى المنصه ثم تقسمها حسب النوع للتسهيل
على المستخدمين ويمكن ان تجني منها 20
جنيها استرلينيا في الساعه الوظيفه
الثانيه المساعد الافتراضي توقعات بزياده
عمليات البحث عن هذه الوظيفه بنسبه
137% خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله يقوم
صاحبها بالرد على رسائل البريد الالكتروني
وتحديد المواعيد ويمكن الربح منها 30 الى
60 جنيها استرلينيا في الساعه الوظيفه
الثالثه هي النسخ الصوتي زاد البحث عن هذه
الوظيفه بنسبه 39% خلال العام الماضي
تعتمد على تحويل الصوت او الفيديو الى نص
مكتوب تحقق يصل الى 22 جنيها استرلينيا في
الساعه اما الوظيفه الرابعه هي مجموعه
التركيز على الانترنت تقضي بالمشاركه الى
جانب عدد محدود من الاشخاص في عمليه
الاستطلاع الاراء وتستخدم عاده هذه
الوظيفه بل تستخدم في ابحاث السوق
والانتخابات مثلا وتحقق ما يصل الى 25
جنيها استرلينيا في الساعه تتعلق الوظيفه
الخامسه بموقعي يوتيوب وتيك توك يتم من
خلالها الدفع لك مقابل مشاهده مقاطع فيديو
طويله على يوتيوب ثم اختصارها بمقاطع
صغيره وتحميلها على تيك توك يمكن ان
يتراوح الراتب ما بين الفي الى 5000 جنيه
استرليني شهريا
[موسيقى]